let's see if we can get 200 I don't know
let's try the 6/8 - area code caller
from 6-8 - welcome
I'm David I'm Thomas what's on your mind
I was wondering this has been something
that I wanted to ask you for a while
yeah do you think there's like a limit
on people being allowed to speak in
public areas like if they keep doing if
they keep saying and doing things that
attract a lot of negative attention like
what I mean is uh recently there was
this rally and flow in the University of
Florida I think with Richard Spencer and
like wherever he goes all of his Nazi
friends some come along and bill I think
three of them got arrested for firing a
gun at a crowd right and I feel like
that would be beyond the limited entry
speech yes but the thing is like he goes
places and he attracts these kinds of
people in these event and these
incidents keep happening got it
Zillah it makes me think like and it
makes me think like maybe maybe there
should maybe there's a limit where
people can legally say we can't host you
because you're such a public hazard yeah
so listen a lot of people Thomas are
trying to kind of reinvent the wheel on
these issues the law is pretty clear
about all of this stuff there's really
no great mystery we know when issues of
actual First Amendment limitations apply
they don't apply and really any of these
college speaking types of situations if
the college doesn't want to invite
someone to speak they don't have to
invite the person to speak they can give
any reason for not inviting that person
to speak that falls under the umbrella
of what you're talking about they can
say we don't have an interest in this
person speaking or there isn't enough
demand to give this person space at one
of our
speaking halls they can say we are not
able to provide security such that it
would be appropriate for the number and
types of people that would show up if
this person were to speak they can do
all of that stuff and and they're
completely allowed to do that I would
love to speak at Stanford I would love
to go tomorrow and speak to a crowd of
15,000 people at Stanford right does
that mean that there's a demand for
15,000 people to come and see me does
that mean that Stanford has to host me
of course it doesn't separate welcome
board here the individuals that will go
up yeah go ahead um I've been in Spencer
and his lawyer sue the University of
Florida so they could so that they had
to host I have no idea I haven't heard
that and I don't know how that would
possibly succeed I don't know how anyone
can force an institution well they don't
want to have uh apparently they had to
fork over like half a million dollars
for security there because I'll look
into it I'll not heard that I have not
heard that I I heard that and it's like
they apparently can't say no to these
guys for first a minute because it's
like a public university private one
okay well then I demand that they host
me how far am I gonna get with that you
know I there's got to be more to it and
I'll look into it Thomas I don't know
specifically offhand what ultimately
ended up happening with that but if it
were that simple than anyone would just
demand that they be given a speaking gig
and it would be a very very different
world than the one we have all right
let's go to break we will answer your
questions next